[Music]
in israel's occupation of palestine its
tactics have become increasingly
aggressive over the decades so too it's
crackdown on media workers covering the
conflict
the targeted killing of al jazeera
journalists and palestinian american
shireen abuukly the latest example
in may 2021 an israeli air raid brought
down a building in the gaza strip that
housed local people and international
media offices including those of al
jazeera
press freedom advocates said it was an
attempt to silence journalists
a month later israeli police destroyed
al jazeera equipment and arrested
jerusalem correspondent
breaking her head in the process
witnesses said her press sign was
clearly visible and the arrest was
unprovoked
abu akley was also in her press vest and
helmet at the time of her death
time and time again
it has been shown that you know israeli
forces kill palestinians including
palestinian journalists without cause in
the occupied territory and it's very
it's extremely rare that israeli
soldiers captains or military officials
are ever held accountable for their
actions israel often uses what it calls
secret evidence to detain palestinian
journalists for months without due
process and restrict their movements
attacks by israeli forces have also left
dozens injured
a palestinian center for human rights
report in 2020 found journalists face
quote cruel inhumane and degrading
treatment at the hands of israeli forces
in the wake of abu aklay's death
israel's army says it does not target
journalists and its foreign minister
suggested conducting a joint
investigation and autopsy
an offer palestinian leaders refused
israeli forces have directly targeted
journalists with lethal force in the
past
in 2008 israeli soldiers killed reuters
cameraman fadel shanna
he filmed the tank as it fired the shell
that killed him
his final images captured on tape before
his camera was destroyed
shana too was wearing body armor marked
press at the time of his death
shireen abu aklay was killed covering an
israeli raid on janine in the occupied
west bank
the qatar-based broadcaster said
al-jazeera producer ali al-samudi was
also wounded
the latest casualties of israeli attacks
on journalists that seem to go on with
impunity
zain basravi al-jazeera
the executive director of the
international press press institute
barbara trionfi says it's important to
find out if shireen abu aklar was
targeted
it has been a terrible news that we
received this morning and we are very
very saddened
about the the killing of shireen um
unfortunately
it also comes
at the time when we have seen an
increase in the killings of journalists
around the world except precisely this
year and where we have seen an increase
in attacks against the press
in the uh in the west bank and gaza so
against palestinian journalists in
particular so this um we are um of
course as as al jazeera we are also
following the news and and pushing will
be putting out the statement very soon
calling for an independent investigation
into this case it's very important to
understand whether uh shireen has been
targeted unfortunately um
the the the information we have received
so far uh appear that it could have been
the case which obviously would be a very
serious crime um however the most
important thing now is that there is an
independent investigation into this case
and we know how hard it will be to get
there you know there is a principle
which is core to journalism is core to
coverage of any conflict any crisis
which is journalists cannot be targeted
that's and that's a war crime so that is
a principle that we need to fight to
defend and we cannot compromise on this
so definitely ipi will use all its
all its um
you know reach and uh internet chat like
reach to international organizations and
uh members to ensure that there is
a clear investigation and understand who
who is behind this killing and whether
it was a targeted killing unfortunately
it seems that uh you know there was no
confrontation between palestinian
fighters and in the israeli army at that
moment in that spot so it seems that the
group of journalists has been targeted
however
as you know the facts are still
unfolding so we need to understand what
happened